that's a new one
sorry guys i'm very distracted i do have
a foster dog who is
very handicapped who i'm trying who just
wants time and i'm just trying to get
him i think i'm further handicapping him
you just want to hang out with me okay
ready all right sorry he's only got one
front leg
he's so heavy okay i got you i got you
okay
you're there you're good hold on am i
abusing the dog i'm trying to save
okay you're fine you're fine just sit
with me sit with me you'll be good
shh okay there we go
sorry you guys are having to see me live
soon
huh did i unplug my computer no he
unplugged something down there oh he's
he's sabotaging the whole podcast baby
you got to just stay here sorry guys
we're having an
animal uh drama
thank you sorry we've these dogs have
been inside and we've been gone so much
he's been creating crates a lot
and he just wants to participate is this
audio gonna be annoying with him panting
yeah this is just uh they're telling me
no no we're leaving this in
you guys you know this is my oh it's
okay
is grace okay is grace okay it's magic
okay let's stop and let's
let's do i think magic might have fell
on his nose okay
just give me a second to think uh do we
have leashes um
grace just to put him i think he's gonna
need him
now he's just trying to what do you need
he needs something hi everyone whitney's
giving up her career to take care of a
dog
so we were now taking over the podcast
um
full time we're gonna talk with um what
are we gonna talk about
are you doing stand up we're never gonna
talk about ancestral trauma here are the
things we're not gonna talk about
oh i know oh never mind she's back she
started her
teacher we thought you gave your career
up to take care of animals but she's
back now so
she's trying to send more animals i'm
gonna be in audio
editing send uh
well then i'm sending this one to you
well no i know a lot of people do not
like eating on the podcast but dog's
panting is adorable what kind of
psychopath doesn't like a handicapped
dog kind of panting
huh what's showing the wall is showing
oh right that's oh sorry and that's a
real wall
because we're real you thought that was
a prop wall honestly
this isn't a set yes just start over
like we just are starting now
okay but we're not right right we're
using that right emily's trying to cut
he's
trying to silence me and d platform me
and censor platform you and i
i will not have it not the platform she
took off the whole network
okay now i'm sweating and covered and
done she's panting that's a different
pant
notice the difference in panting today's
episode the guest is
the great kevin nelen if he needs an
introduction frankly i feel sorry for
you
you know him as a legend from snl
he's in many an adam sandler movie i
he's actually such a good friend that i
don't even know half of his credits but
he's
of all my friends when i got in public
with besides maybe david spade he's the
most recognized what about sandra
bullock
i don't we don't go out in public she
won't let anyone know that we're friends
with central
cop we're not public friends we're
private friends
but no he because he's been so famous
for so long
and to me one of the main sort of things
i love about kevin so much
and this is probably going to come off
every time i try to compliment someone
it comes off as an insult i just can't
help it
pretend like you're complimenting
someone you don't know you're good at
that
okay my brain just froze it's like but
but here's the thing kevin nealon he's
so funny in snl and in movies but
when you meet him he's even funnier like
just as a person in conversation he's so
funny it's like shocking like you miss
half of the shit he says
because i'm too busy trying to think of
a funny thing to say that's a good
compliment yeah okay good because
he's just so funny and then um we did i
did his uh he does this
uh camp not camping a hiking show called
hiking with kevin
where he has like super famous people go
on hikes and this is how incredible
kevin nealon is he manages to make that
entertaining like everyone's out of
breath and everyone's like i
got sweating and disgusting and it's
still like really fun and entertaining
to watch
and we're doing a version of it right
now i know and this is what the show is
like
when you watch it i'm not out of breath
i swear um okay so we have been
touring all around this great country of
ours we've there's been so many
insane things happening on stage oh my
god there's a guy in the front room he's
wearing a shirt that says i love pimples
get up here right now
get up here right now get up here right
now right now look at this look at this
it's a fucking man
[Applause]
do you want to talk to her oh jesus
christ this is really intense
holly holly her name is holly noel
that's her middle name
i almost feel like we need to make a
documentary about it or something i
don't know if it's just that people
haven't been out in a year
so when they come to the shows they're
especially nuts and feral and excited
i don't i don't know if if everyone just
thought they were going to die last year
and they're just like fuck it like
we you know that yeah that is definitely
is that what it is that's
acting nuts at shows i mean that's how
all of us are acting so i i said
that's a good point so i assume they're
right there with us there's just an esp
like a next
level of berserk happening in comedy
clubs right now that i've i've been
performing
at and every so i naturally have to
bring people up on stage and just see
the crazy up close
there was a bachelorette party and i
believe it was when we were in dallas
okay and oh as you guys
know week two on using this incredibly
advanced your bachelorette party because
you're stealing a lot of focus
[Applause]
so she came all the way up on stage
bless her heart which by the way in the
south bless your heart means
not anything good
here my name is
she looks so happy she has she oh my
gosh she had on the little dick uh
dick necklaces brenda what are you
getting married next week
we can try the music on a tiny bit so i
can hear him you're getting married
next week yes ma'am yeah where
uh it's at a nature preserve in plano
texas oh my gosh
a nature person texas what is your uh
what does your man do
he's a marine okay that's
keep in mind that i said that do you
like that in with in bachelorette
parties usually it's the girls they're
like look at her she looks like
she looks so sweet so down to her so
right
and then immediately it gets time for a
wedding and they're like veil sash
dicks it's like they become a different
person they're like this is my chance to
show out
so true it's like all these girls and
little draper james rhys witherspoon
outfits and look at me and my
my picnic table for the gangnam and my
little i might go to the farmer's market
but i'll talk
and then it's their bachelorette party
like dick she'll blend my mouth
they're all drunk they're like you
thought i wasn't fun why am i gonna
marry them bitch like what the hell
it's so true it is sweet because she's
wearing a little like a little sweet
little dress
go right to church the dick the dick
hanging around your neck doesn't really
match uh the paisley print
and then how did you know he was the one
i just knew
we've been together in high school for a
long time so
funny yeah he's like yeah he's 94.
and then um how did he propose he did it
in the mountains
this is so sweet how old are you i'm 19.
you did a show in my hometown plot twist
plot twist
[Applause]
wow that's why she's confused about how
the dick goes
i mean 19. i talked about her wet ass
pussy i talk about dicks on her like i
just was like
and what do you say to someone when you
are looking at them and you're like
you're having a bachelorette party for a
relationship
that i know it's not going to work out
but you don't know it so what do i do
19. i know i was like high school
sweetheart it's not see
that makes the story less sweet but it's
also like can you even be in here this
is 21 and over like are you even allowed
you've set your own standards for
comments i don't even know what can you
i think it's 18 and up
oh because i thought it was service i'm
pretty sure i don't know but her whole
family was there i was just like you can
go into a club at 18 unless they say to
otherwise
oh i see they're just not allowed to get
alcohol yeah i don't know
what's happening oh my gosh so that was
really stressful
but this entire weekend uh emily was
being so
funny so funny the entire time and
then that could be any weekend there was
a night that we were just like drinking
and like hanging out and what do you
drink a prosecco
sour with cum on top what's it called uh
what is it a
pearl necklace okay she gets a drink
that's in a little like
like um as if she's uh uh you know
um yeah in monaco holding this little
like fancy thing with half of its cream
like
i thought it was like a russian white
russian or something i don't know what
are they called creamy nipples or
something what was it a pico sour
piece goes sour when i did shame her
about it on instagram everyone came to
your defense and said that it's very
delicious and it's a peruvian drink and
that it's lovely
but whoever put the roofies in it went
overboard because emily was just going
off
that night being so funny and she just
slipped by as we're talking she's like
well when i did stand up i was like wait
when you did what
and she's like oh because i did a couple
stand-up stats like and i was like you
said my life's a joke
i was like wait what do you mean you did
stand up this is someone that i've known
for eight years
i used to work at snl like this is
someone that's seen comedy from
every angle the one thing i did not know
she did was stand up so in my head i'm
like oh she did this when she was like
22 and i was like oh when was this she
was like it was like two years ago
[Laughter]
so i i told her i had to see i had to
see her set
and she had to show it to me so we
watched emily
let us watch her stand up are you sure
you're okay with us airing this
premiering this
well we've already called it what else
can we do
the world premiere but the reason come
on in let's see what you got the reason
you like this story is because of
how it ended up which is the shared
album
oh that's right okay hold on hold on
back up emily will you please tell the
story
of i can't believe i just remembered
this
so emily told me this story go
it's a talk it's a tough listen
once well it all starts when once i had
a boyfriend
and i decided to start doing stand-up
but i didn't tell whitney because i knew
she'd be super threatened so
i went to do my little set and this was
my second set i believe
and i asked
i figured i was so good i was gonna
i was gonna apply for a um i was gonna
submit myself to an nbc stand-up contest
because i've done it second set ever she
said here's my special
yeah i've edited it was four minutes so
i asked a guy in the audience to record
it so
one of the guys that wasn't allowed to
leave because he'd also paid seven
dollars to be there
my big finale joke okay is about
hpv like finding out you ain't you have
hpv everyone has hpv don't come at me
i was joking around being at the doctor
and the doctor telling you you have hpv
and then hoping that you have the cancer
kind and not the wart kind
right so i was like made a joke about
like because i i'd rather have the
cancers than the warts the warts don't
ever go away
so just being like relieved right which
i thought was a very good job yeah
it's like yes i was praying for the
cancer kind of right because you'd
rather die than have warts cut it love
it totally
right so you and then you find out you
have the cancer cry and you're like
thank god hilarious laughter and suit so
i couldn't figure out how to get it from
my phone to the computer
which is why she was a great hire uh for
this show
i'm creatively show running so i
figure so i figure okay well this
cable's not working i can't get in the
computer so i'm just gonna put it in the
cloud i'm gonna put it in an
album and then the album i can find on
my computer you dropped an album already
damn you were on spotify she was like
i'll just do an album i can't get the
video up we'll do an album you know what
i'll just
take a selfie make some cover art i got
an album i hear your universe
listening always i i put it in an album
and i didn't realize at the time but i
uploaded it to my boyfriend at the
time's
family's shared hawaii photo album
where i belong which means but the
problem is
that his mother is a cervical cancer
survivor
first of all that's not the only problem
and isn't she lucky
so what's that what's the issue here
okay so so didn't the sister call you
what happened so the sister calls me
hey m um great set like other
first of all there's so many once you've
seen the set which we will
premiere live on good for you that joke
was like
five minutes in so the fact that the
more horrifying part of the story is not
that they heard you joking about
cervical cancer
it said they had to listen to four
minutes of other jokes before like they
they did watch the whole thing was he
she he we're just good
well no i i it is definitely your lord
you can't say nothing around you
about this thing okay there's nothing i
must say
emily noonan is the comedian that's made
me laugh the hardest of any comedian
because i've been laughing
for i i am laughing so hard there's
videos of me laughing so hard that i
like truly
cannot breathe i mean this is me
[Music]
i don't know what to do i need this is a
good idea
literally falling crying i'm laughing so
hard
delusional i'm scared for myself you
realized how crazy you were in this
moment i'm scared for myself
after watching this i
this is the set that went to your this
one went to your
boyfriend's ma by the way emily is
i mean i've never had this much
confidence on stage and i've been doing
this for 15 years
um so rough year for
successful men right they're having a
rough year i have a rough year too but
nobody
makes a big deal out of that um i
as a someone that pretends to be like an
outraged feminist on social media i'm
very happy about the me too movement
it's long overdue
you're so polite also well spoken
[Laughter]
just because it's long overdue okay i'm
not getting i'm not going to get into
you're kind of using your customer
service voice too just a little bit
but it's also like i'm not going to get
into why it's longer in the hand
i only have three minutes this hand
right here
and then the fact that she's doing what
two or three minutes and
no like i'm gonna upload this to the nbc
website but i'm not gonna like memorize
any of my jokes i had a piece of paper
who was tired for that like everybody's
jokes is really hard
i want them to see my raw talent and how
this just rolls off my tongue and i'm
just thinking it not that i'm just gonna
check my notes real quick
um i have been disappointed by men
myself obviously i
have a father the timing on that is
pretty good
it's pretty good but i actually worked
with harvey weinstein i worked with him
for two years
okay you can't this is i love that
you're enunciating i love
that so much i saw him all the time i
was alone with him occasionally
and he had the audacity to never
touch me like he couldn't all i'm
thinking is what do you mean you worked
with harvey weinstein for two years
we're all commute we're homeless
like what doing what everyone's like all
the people listening yeah
emily is like so guys i've had a huge
career yeah i like work with harvard
i was with him every day for two years
like what i'll be sending him my tape
personally
i didn't even need this all this
auditioning everyone's like cool then
why are you at the wall comedy show
paying to do stand up for a bunch of
homes because i want to see you pose in
my hand in my pocket yeah it's like
everyone's like you should have fucked
harvey weinstein
this is what happens when women don't
fuck harvey weinstein they end up in
basement they're like it's going to be
really hard
um like i think he once told me that my
fly was open
like you couldn't believe that is that
true
in an elevator what happened your
zipper's down
and you said oh and he was like please
cover up anything sexual about you
so you're the only woman harvey once
didn't want to undress but want to dress
correct like wait she he he'd be like
you want to be in the audience wait for
my next bill cosby zinger
oh oh hold on dan you were hitting them
all it's kind of like finding out that
you were like not unconscious in front
of bill cosby and he just like
called the paramedics like waiting for
them that is
really funny emily it is like actually
but you you said it like you hated the
joke like you were
you know i mean you were like long
overdue i'm not making a joke about bill
cosby because it's long overdue and i do
not approve of his behavior but i know i
need to use his name for this joke and i
know this is gonna kill
even though i even though i'm
known this is a no-no guys i like pandas
i really relate to pandas
um they sleep all day and they're not
sleeping they're eating they have sex
once a year
and everybody's trying to like
reinvigorate their zest for life and
they're just like
leave us alone they just want to extinct
themselves um
i like kids
spoiler alert i did not hear back from
nbc what i love about this is that no
matter who you are
or what or no matter what comedy looks
the same
for everyone so true if this is
literally there's not one person who's
in comedy you could show that to me like
yeah that's me yeah yeah yeah 100 no my
first sets i was just like
like i don't know i was like in a
different you just have a uh
not a confidence a a almost i was like
you're welcome
i'm barely here i do this so much i'm
barely here
my first says i was just like i'm gonna
talk about every celebrity i can think
of because that's what i think people do
on tv
as if i was their friend in real life
wait didn't you have a celebrity story
recently or like a you had a hollywood
moment
because are you going to leave for my
hollywood moment oh yeah go
go send them to my big hollywood moment
tell me um last month as you know our
taxes were due
yeah what is that um i
did not know that when i was working um
before my promotion that i was hourly
enough salary someone definitely told me
i'm sure
and your boy didn't pay no taxes last
year
and owes taxes and i said oh
right now wait no no no and i said that
is
very celebrity of me oh to it when i get
to it
wait wait wait so because i remember the
first time i had to pay
that i actually owed taxes i had spent
all the money in my bank account because
i thought because i didn't
save up for taxes later yeah and i
couldn't afford the taxes the first year
that i made a lot of money
well here's the thing i'm like i know
about taxes i'm not an idiot yeah i knew
i should i i knew that
but are you a corporation are you no i'm
not but i also didn't
for some reason and someone definitely
told me for sure i was like
someone handled no for sure i was told
like we're not taking taxes out
but i was probably doing something or i
was doing something else i'm sure yeah
and i was just like so i would get my
checks and i was like lovely and then
didn't ever
look to see if taxes were coming out of
them and so i'm just like oh okay well
what i'll get you when i get you i'll
get you when i get you and then so you
start i just fouled him and they said
hey you owe this money and i said well
we'll work something out look at you'll
i was like this is very la to just be
like i'm not paying them
i mean still haven't paid him well no i
set up a payment plan i paid what i
could out of my like
because i have emergency money that i
said because i'm not crazy with money
yeah yeah so i i used the emergency
money to pay what i could and then i was
like and the rest you'll get
in increments throughout the next couple
years um
you'll get it when you get it i'm gonna
i'm gonna put the government on layaway
and haven't you taken enough i mean what
more i mean especially
had you also never paid california taxes
before no tennessee didn't have taxes
like that
so they also wanted some money too oh no
was that's the first way everyone's
leaving shouldn't you be happy i stay
you should pay me to stay here yeah why
don't you give me that money because
it is how much more is it like in terms
of percentage if you're in a no
how much do they want from me california
wanted a good couple thousand from me uh
yeah and i have a one account there's
all my bills and everything and i have
one that's just fun like for me
but um i mean it'll be fine i just
thought it was really funny magoobies
baltimore june 10th through 12th
will be there limited tickets left and
then codependent tour with whitney
comings in taylor tomlinson that's july
23rd in
reno um the mirage las vegas
uh august 7th and i swear she'll be
there i won't be a moron i'm gonna
i'm gonna dress up i swear and not wear
uh pajamas
uh and then the merch is out the merch
is out merch is out
merch tell me about it it is first of
all it is
edgy iconic people are gonna ask about
your whatever you're wearing right now
why isn't that our merch
well because we don't have the
livestream it's advertising has anyone
figured out what this is does everyone
know these are the houses from edward
scissorhands on his
hoodie and the little little topiary
holy shit that's
where did you get that dumb good dumb
good
they do they just take shows and movies
and stuff i love it it looks a little
flammable
but i love it it smells flammable
uh new merch is out you will know where
to get it and um
enjoy kevin nealon please don't write
elephants
you know what i learned about karaoke
huh whatever song you're picking up
okay there you go in a karaoke place no
yeah first you gotta be in the carrier
collection
no whatever song you pick
before you start singing the lyrics you
come in on it
like you start the song like
the lyrics haven't come up yet the music
is going you go like
whenever i see you then
you know what i mean i don't i wasn't
paying attention you rev up all right
i'm gonna do it again i wasn't making
it i was looking myself in the camera
what
the great the legend kevin is doing
comedy i have better things to do like
check out myself in the
camera i'm ready
um i noticed that in karaoke night um
if you want to really fool people before
you start seeing the lyrics of the song
you kind of rev up with a little like
warm up
as coming up on lyrics like give me a
name of a song
um wild thing wow thing okay wow
thing you know then you go into it
because you're hearing you're going wow
he's got a voice
but why i like to just put my finger in
my and just
people isn't it the nose you put it in
it yeah
i love that you said that because you
just revealed that we're real friends
i know a lot about you that's the first
thing i ask people when they come to the
podcast i say are we friends
we are friends but only in little doses
what does it even mean but i also think
that there's
a limit to how close you can be to a
married man
you know what i mean what we're talking
about close or friends we became
friends you don't know how we originally
met
at a knicks game i know yup what was i
playing we
met at a knicks game in new york yes so
when you
get to sit on the court or whatever
because they think you're famous or
confused with sarah silverman or however
i got there i'm not sure
but uh we were upstairs and there's like
a room
with a buffet yeah it was the uh what's
called the vip vip lounge
you were with susan a one susan
yagli who i believe you might have been
engaged to at the time not married
i don't know how i would have gotten
into a knicks game if i wasn't on snl
maybe they maybe it's my ex-wife maybe
nope uh-uh it was soup
i was i remember it because i called my
it ruined the relationship
i was currently in because i saw your
relationship with her
have i never done have i never told you
this story
i think you might have but i dismissed
this the covent fog
i just missed it you're kevin
yes and when did you stop yes landing do
you know who i saw
up in there in that lounge i think i've
gone to maybe two or three games
woody allen once i took uh have you seen
the documentary i took a piss next to
woody allen okay i did see the
documentary
and walter cronkite wow and walter
cronkite i must have been doing weekend
update at the time because he saw me he
goes
i want to hear a dirty joke and he
pulled me to the side
oh no and he told me a dirty joke a bj
joke
oh no was it funny
i don't know remember the joker still
like
i can't believe that walter cronkite
just did that
i have a theory a lot of journalist like
on-air
journalists i feel like wanted to be
actors or comics
brian williams all these guys when you
meet them they're like they they're
life of the party and i'm like aren't
you supposed to be an objective journal
like i feel like they're
wise guys you know
do you think i'm doing a character right
now i feel like we're not i feel like
you're
a character who is very methodically
taking that final top off when he's
listening
drinking and paying attention you're
doing a character who's just letting my
story bomb horrible
not hearing anything just putting a
screw in the cap
by the way it's not that different from
kevin
i'm sorry what was the story again but i
do want to
say about you and sue you guys were
um i call her sue no one calls her sue
you don't call her sue
i i'll type i'll go sues susan yeah
you guys were doing this you would say
every piece of food you would see she
would go
i like my women like i like my almonds
yeah and then you would say whatever and
you told your boyfriend why can't we do
that yeah like brown and in a bowl like
or whatever it was
and you guys would just crack each other
up it was you two
in the corner like cracking each other
up at the buffet and it made me so
mad because i was like i felt that i
felt that anger i was like
relationship's supposed to be
fun like they're cracking each other up
like that's what friendships are
and then i was in like such a crazy bad
relationship and then i and it fuck it
fucked up like my
you ruined my life i'm sorry well
luckily there was only one bad
relationship you had
yeah yeah only one yeah after that it
was smooth sailing
yeah yeah well i'm sorry but i'm glad
i'm glad that that looked like um we
were creatively
fun um
but we're real friends we are friends i
i've always respected you
as a producer and a writer and a comic
and i also admire your
your um energy and your um
ambition you're very ambitious and um
all things that make a difficult
relationship
all things that make you a nightmare to
me no but i'm so grateful to you because
you um have been like
it's tricky it's like you're so much
wildly more like successful and
and you're a legend and but you never
let people
feel like they're beneath you you know
like i feel like you for some weird
reason treat people that are not equal
to
like equals like comics and stuff and i
felt like we could be friends for some
reason i felt
i mean it sounds delusional looking back
the fact that it really does seem
it's weird and you've never been creepy
you've never been
you've just always i don't know i just
you're the greatest
oh thank you very much you've never
flirted with me i'm frankly offended
and i want an answer why well what don't
i have
that you want a you're wrong i flirted
with you but it is so discreet
you don't even know yeah this is a long
game trying to make me jealous with
susan i see what you're doing i see what
you're doing
i went out of my way to get married i
had a kid
yeah well what if i did flirt with you i
i probably would have done whatever you
wanted
like an old i mean an older successful
comedian that i looked up to like i mean
you had
all the power of the world to do
anything you ever wanted and you see i
know you just did
jokes in movies and very boring got
married what's wrong with one guy i've
always been married even when i wasn't
married for
three years i was married to myself
i didn't even sleep around or anything i
didn't even like you know
maybe i was with one or two people but
no
sex or anything you're just like a
serial monogamist i think so
at least when i'm not in the marriage
um you once said that one of the
funniest things i've ever heard i have
like a list of the time that's not true
no i'm
are you ready yeah do you want you sound
like my son are you ready are you ready
show me something so i always want to
show you something are you ready oh
that's so cute
yeah i'm always ready man um uh
no daddy's on instagram um
uh you were on the adam carolla show
this must have been
15 16 years ago i just like moved to l.a
maybe even longer and i would listen to
adam carolla's radio show in the morning
okay and it was 97.1
and adam carolla had this you know gift
of just being able to talk
and talk and talk about fucking anything
anything like we're doing like we're
doing now
he was kind of doing podcasts kind of
before how do people get in a room with
nobody else and just a stalk
but he would get in the room with a huge
celebrity who'd he'd be like where are
you from you're like uh they'd be like
lady gaga would be like i'm from
illinois like well when i was in
illinois and then he would just tell the
story about himself
for 40 minutes i know it
so so here's the thing about illinois
the person's like why did why am i here
like it was like a jumping-off point so
but i was obsessed with listening to him
and it was very hypnotic to me and i
wanted to learn from him because he was
so confident and
i would listen to him i would sit
outside my car above the comedy store i
lived
right above the common store miller
drive and i would sit in my car and
listen to him because i didn't have a
radio inside
it was it wasn't on the computer yet you
were on promoting
a stand-up special you had done at the
was it the el portal theater
probably and you said uh
we're shooting uh i shot at the el
portal theater in burbank
and he said oh i went to high school in
burbank and you went yeah that's why we
shot it there
and i was like it was just like he
didn't and he was like anyway my high
school like he just went on about a
20-minute tangent and it's like i don't
think you even realized how
funny that was to me at the moment
because i'm always like
he he'll turn everything around and
figure out a way to make it
about him it's in my top five like brody
stevens
yelling at the comedy store audience on
new year's eve in like 2007 is like my
number
one and guess who was my warm-up back at
the el portal theater
one brody stevens yeah
we love brodie stevens google him so you
know we talked about doing this podcast
a couple days ago with all you guys
there's a chain a thread
and we're trying to figure out a day oh
and and i thought for some reason you
lived way out in west lake
and i thought oh what a nightmare drive
all the way out there rush hour traffic
it's gonna take me at least two hours
all right and you still said yeah she
went on my hike
i like her i'm gonna go out there i
could flirt with her uh i don't know
this is what we do comedians resentfully
go and talk to each other
no for free what is this so there's
one thing worse than getting stuck in
traffic
leaving two hours early and getting
stuck in traffic
leaving two hours early and there's no
traffic so you have to stall for two
hours i can't believe you just said this
because today i did a podcast this
morning i was 30 minutes late and i
realized i'm sorry early
and i realized being early is actually
ruder than being late
yes yes the people were like frazzled
the guy's hair was wet
like didn't we talk about this on my
hike i did with you is it rude to be
is it rude i think we did it yes
that's so funny you edited it so you
remembered but when i did your hike i
was sick and i remember nothing you were
so nice i was
really sick i had like bronchitis or
something yes you had no voice
oh that was everybody's
i literally could not speak everyone's
like i love that interview i'm like i
could barely it was like i had like the
faintest little whisper of a
thing and so i sat at the top of the
hill you know top of the canyon there's
a little lookout place
up here today and i spent about 20
minutes there kind of um
ruminating looking at all your
instagrams just to remember who you are
and then refresh the hippocampus i just
drove down
and there was a starbucks right there so
i
i had to use the bathroom so i thought
well i'll go in there and kill like 10
minutes
so i went in there and i felt sometimes
i feel like i have to order something
you know if you go in you do and you're
kevin neal and you're famous yeah so for
kevin ellen to walk in and go to the
bathroom for 10 minutes and leave is a
bad story a bad way to leave a bunch of
people that have twitter
right so i got in there and before i use
a bathroom i ordered toilet paper
no i said i said you have a bathroom i
see it's over there i said oh great
now i'm trying not to eat when i don't
want to eat and whenever i go to
starbucks i'll get either that
egg bites egg fajita wrap you know egg
bites are good
feta cheese wrap and the egg bites are
probably
the healthiest yeah but i'll or i'll get
a little vanilla scone
or bix going i didn't want to get on
that train again because i've been so
good like i was telling them like like
the last two days i've been
really good with my diet because i've
gained i get a lot of weight over the
pandemic
because food tastes so much better when
you don't have covid
that's true um but anyway so i didn't
order anything
i came out of the bathroom there's other
people uh in front of
ordering i said well i'm not gonna wait
here for this this is so rude
i just left but people don't really
recognize me anymore
i don't think you know what here's what
i think is happening
i don't think people don't recognize you
because i had this too
because i was like because my hair blew
remember the did you watch the comeback
with lisa kudrow yeah the least uh
episode is it episode six in the first
season when she i think it was um
minute seven and episode six
and she she goes to the people's choice
awards and she wants to look young and
hip
so instead of wearing her signature uh
mickey red waves she does like a
straight blow out like a smokey eye to
try to be young
and none of the paparazzi know who she
is
so she goes i should have come as me
that's great but i always say that when
i'm like out and probably get someone
doesn't recognize my marriage
um but i think what's happening is
because i felt like that too i was like
are people not recognizing me as much or
also it's coveted no one wants to talk
to anybody so i've been recognized
more with a mask on without a mask
that's so interesting
but i will tell you it doesn't bother me
i don't mind not getting recognized i
think everyone is so on their phones now
that they're not
they're not not right they're not seeing
anyone no i i need this to be true for
me
because i don't think i'm getting
recognized as much but everyone's on
their phones i kind of like it
that's true but you know it used to be
no one's sitting in line just looking
at people okay one time you just looked
around without stood in line and didn't
just stare at your phone the whole time
it depends on what restaurant you're at
yeah but i used to be where i would walk
into a restaurant
heads would turn you know like why does
he get a table before us
yeah right but no but um you know i
wouldn't get recognized but anyway
and and it was a very gradual thing
where i stopped getting recognized so
much
you know and and and i was fine with
that i didn't even know it
i was in austin doing a a radio gig a
friend of mine dale dudley does a show
in austin
and we've been friends for a long time
he's like the howard stern of austin you
know
and then we'll go out afterwards or the
next day and meet for lunch but he's not
psyched joe rogan just moved there
it's probably not so we sit we sit in
this restaurant he goes he goes you know
what i noticed about you
just about a year ago he goes you don't
get recognized as much as you used to
and i never dawned on me and i thought
you know what you're right
you're right and i don't mind it i don't
mind that at all i really don't
can i ask you a question do you think
that on in any way
you're looking for it less so you notice
it less
you know like you find what you're
looking for right for the most part i
think yeah you do when somebody's
looking for a sign
they'll always find it yeah like my wife
is always like ladybloods
ladybugs what about things yeah like if
she has to make a big decision
yeah um and she's thinking one way or
the other
and then she's decided on something and
then she'll see you later because
there's my sign yeah
yes i think it's coincidence but also
but the people that do recognize i'm
finding more and more the ones that do
recognize you
know what you had for breakfast
yesterday whereas it used to be like hey
oh my god you're the girl um
from the thing in the show yes yeah so
and so
now it's like you're whitney cummings
how's your knee
and how is the lyme disease you know
what i'm saying they know so it's like a
quality not quantity thing now yeah
everyone doesn't kind of know you from
something a couple
people at the airport gate like are like
how's your mom doing
you know that's right like they feel so
close to you do you feel like that it's
a different kind of fame since you've
been doing the hiking with kevin
podcast on youtube different kind of
fame yeah it's a more intimate
it's a more outdoorsy fame yep
hey you know we were talking about our
storage units we really were
we got out of business and i gotta tell
you something we were in my storage
units yesterday
i've had a storage unit for at least 15
years when i used to live in manhattan
beach
i have it in el segundo i have a storage
unit where i keep my uh you have them
all over the country
what you keep your iuds in a certain
storage unit
is it that my time
i have probably spent in the last 15
years close to
80 or 90 thousand dollars storing junk
just it's like i'm renting a dumpster
because it's 500
a month it's about 450 a month now and
it's just
nostalgic stuff it's my kids clothes
from when he's one and two
at his crib it's the idea of that to to
save baby clothes
so when you have another baby you'll
have them i think originally that was
the thing in the crib
um so you know it's tough imagine
walking
that's how fucking creepy that storage
unit must be to walk in and just see a
crib and a bunch of baby clothes
and a bunch of like snl posters not
knowing it's kevin neeland's
storage unit i get sad when i go there
and i'm the only one that goes there
because nobody wants to go down there
with me and i walk down it's like going
to a morgue
i i visit that place so infrequently
it's probably i visited the same amount
i'd visit a friend in prison
you know i go down there and i have the
key and i walk in there
and um and i open up that door and it
makes that loud noise and i turn on that
light bulb that bare light bulb
and there's just so much history in
there like you know
and i get sad i see like old stuff you
know that i
that uh parents pictures and uh
ex-wives you know can i ask you a
question my ex-wives all over the place
let me ask you do you you don't need my
permission
do you think you would have been this
nostalgic or it would have been as
emotional
before the pandemic or was it yeah it's
always been
because there's a way that's why i have
a storage unit because i'm nostalgic i
save stuff that
i don't need and and and i'm just paying
for it i keep halloween decorations in
there
and i keep christmas decorations in
there and for that amount of money i
could buy new decorations every year no
but then it would it's
but they're your decker you don't want
to throw them away keep the the special
ones in my garage
that's true that's true but some stuff
you got to keep i'm a big fan of keeping
i mean we went to my storage unit yes
i love going to a storage unit um uh we
went to two of them
and it was uh how what size
ten by ten yeah two big ten by ten uh
ten by six probably not as big as yours
and
we found old journals we i i i it was
nice to put together some of the pieces
now that i've been through therapy a
little bit now that i'm ready to sort of
see what like looking through the
journals and stuff it's like okay i'm
ready to
see what happened yeah you know now you
could step back and look at it
yeah like from the end it was like nine
like whitney sitcom poster it was like
okay that happened like that wasn't a
dream i so enjoyed
watching you develop your sitcom the
whole process
and watching you be on it and watching
it all unfold
because i'm glad you knew that you were
you were
you know you were driven and you were
excited to do it
and you you know you were good you're
good at it
and i just you know i've been doing this
for a long time so i'm always interested
when somebody's starting a new show
and so just watching that come together
and watch going to i went to the table
read
remember that's right over at radford
and um where we would have our table
reads like every day when i was on man
with the plans
and many times i'd be in that room go
this is where whitney did it but they
had the table on this end
and we have ours over here maybe that's
why they should last
i mean i didn't last that much longer
either yeah
but um and then then i remember thinking
at the time
whitney she's a powerhouse she's got
like a sitcom she's got a talk show
she's doing specials you know and now
you're still a powerhouse
yeah reddit doesn't agree with you for
some reason read it reddit just thought
i was
a loud obnoxious uh busted whore
where is our waiter
i know i mean podcasts are like weird
dates
it is it's like um it's like i mean this
would be an entertaining lunch for me if
i was out to lunch with you
yeah this is what we're doing i mean i
remember a time when neither of us had
podcasts
did you do yours kind of out of
obligation well i don't have a podcast
okay well you did a web series oh it's a
series it's a web series
well it's but it's is it thought of as a
website because people say like have you
done kevin's podcast
yeah it's more of a web series okay they
said have you done hiking with kevin
hiking without
it's a big deal it took you a while to
ask me you get giant celebrities
it took me a while to ask you because i
i know how inundated you are with people
asking you to do podcasts
yeah and i'm the same way it gets to a
point where oh
not another one and then they're moving
like to valley and to austin
and who's the most famous person you've
had on your podcast
besides you shut up famous you've had so
many fans like famous probably caitlyn
jenner
yeah yeah sandler i asked
yeah sandler conan i went through all my
friends yeah
kudrow did it that she who cucho is hard
to get on a
web series i got a lot of the friends
yeah i got matt leblanc
lisa kudrow who's the person that was
the hardest to schedule with
matt leblanc kind of strung me along for
a long time
because because it's it is spade says it
is doing a friend's podcast it's like
jury duty
yeah it's just like a matter of time
like you know you have to do it like you
try to put it off as much as you can
like over complimenting it's the same as
like being early now as
um was rude of them being late i think
over complimenting is almost ruder
over and nagging bad but when people
like come into your house you know and
they're like oh this is amazing this is
gorgeous what are 20 million
and you're like no but
yeah like now i feel like an asshole
like there's this one actress
that that emily you might know who it is
who used to always
over compliment me as a way of nagging
me
and it took me so long to figure out
she's like how are you doing
are you dating chris evans
and i'm like no like it was like oh my
god did i just hear
that you just booked um that scorsese
movie
i'd be like nope didn't even get asked
to comment like the over
complimenting so then i had to admit
oh no i'm just a piece of shit she'd be
like oh i thought oh my god i thought
that was you
was that not you oh well you should i've
gotten it
it's like you know good and well that i
didn't fucking get it like what what is
this
that like passive aggressive shit okay
i've been talking to kevin nelen
and if you've heard me talk to kevin
nealon for a prolonged amount of time
you're probably thinking you know what
whitney needs more iron
uh i was energy i was tired during this
episode
started okay because i know that this
interview was a little low energy
because i was not taking care of myself
because i was uh
moving and i truly believe this is not
because we're reading an ad i do believe
it's because i was without my daily
harvest
and when i am left my own devices to eat
without
daily harvest which has it's all out
it's always just gonna be healthy i know
that it's
always healthy always easy always
delicious it's a no-brainer
daily hearts has they have snacks too
not just meals they have they have
little those little protein balls
bites they have you're obsessed with
those
no i i'm obsessed with these things i
don't know why i can't bring them up
it's a cup with everything you need to
make a smoothie
i mean look at this smoothie the
plant-based ice cream which is new that
is delicious and i don't even like ice
cream and i love it also but if you're
somebody who's like rushing around like
on the go
these are great because like you just
blend you blend the smoothies up in the
container they're in and take it with
you there's like no extra
cups and trash and plates and
everything's like the way it is
you can enjoy it in the top you don't
have to make your own hole you don't
have to drink out of it spill on
yourself like an asshole
you have no excuse not to be healthy no
stay cool calm and collected during the
summer heat go to dailyharvest.com and
enter code good for you
to get 25 off your first box that's code
good for you for 25
off your first box at dailyharvest.com
dailyharvest.com.com
and now we are going to talk about
betterhelp.com and i'm not going to make
a joke right now because
i'm so secure with myself after having
therapy that i don't feel the need to be
on all the time i can just sit here and
be my myself because i'm enough benton
take it away before i start crying
okay as someone who's not enough i will
tell you
that better help is someone who's too
much and someone who is
overflowing um better help is great i
actually used it recently
um you told me about this yeah it was
wonderful because here's the thing
whenever you need something like better
help you're not like oh let me get
up let me get dressed let me go
somewhere let me park drive you're not
doing that i'm like i'm in my bed who
can i chat with on my phone that's not
my mom
yes or one of my friends who's just
gonna yeah he's gonna be like he's gonna
be like well i mean
the other day you shut up by the way and
who's not in
therapy either yeah they're all jealous
of you so don't talk to them um
go to your therapist go to
betterhelp.com it was so easy i
literally logged it on my phone
i found someone i want to chat with you
get like options on how you want to chat
what time
it's very easy you can't i mean we
talked on the phone the other day and i
was like you were saying things that
she said that i mean this is going to
sound ego and angle but i was like yeah
that's a
i could tell that's a good therapist if
she said that better help is more
affordable than traditional counseling
you also have financial aid available
that's really important i think
it's available everywhere and this
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp and
good for you listeners get 10 off their
first month
at betterhelp.com whitney do you think
you over analyze too much
nope not slightest
i'm i don't hold on to anything well of
course that's our job as comedians is to
break things down over analyze here's
what i'm trying to get rid of
ameliorate ameliorate like my great work
regularly yup
yup i do i'm trying to teach my kid a
new word every day okay what's what's
give me some recent ones we used to do
that on this podcast but no one liked it
yeah we used to do word of the day no
one
appreciated it we would learn a new word
every week and i'd use it twice in the
podcast
acorn
um what word give me some good words
there's i think on social media
and in stand-up there's too much use of
the word guys
hey guys hey guys how's it going guys
guys are you like me
guys hey guys well no that's i mean
that's my fault
so do you do that it's an attack yes i
mean probably
i do like guys but you know i got in
trouble because people go like oh you
shouldn't say guys anymore because it's
a gendered thing
which brought me to this uh i was trying
to work on a bit about this i was trying
to work on a joke about this you'll tell
me
if it's worth thinking about any longer
about i want to hear about your ring
this ring that's a bee yeah i got it
yesterday on the shoot someone um the
stylist
unit i didn't even know i had it
um about like saying like hey guys or
whatever and then
it got into this conversation on twitter
about whether you should
be able to use pet names for people in
the workplace like honey sweetie
you know what up chief what up you know
like sort of how
and i was thinking about it because i do
that i go like hey baby hey cupcake like
i just hey honey honey i do
i'm like honey can i have a thing i do
it and
i and everyone's a good sexist you and i
was like okay yes
i know you should be mad at me but it's
i'm not
demeaning you it's just that sexually
it's just i
i i don't i didn't go
i didn't remember your name get me on
that
i'm saying get me on that don't get me
on the sexism thing get me on the fact
that i just didn't bother to learn your
name
because i'm not doing it because i'm
trying i want to call you that i just i
don't remember your name so i just have
to say something do you feel it
it's much more difficult now to do
stand-up because you don't want to
offend anybody
you're going to get called so much
funnier now i think all of this has made
us
like fucking so much funnier you can
just go and go like
what up bitches and everyone thank god
someone said something
edgy for once it's what i think cancer
culture doesn't understand they're just
making us stronger
because comedians like we operate in
spaces that are taboo and we
say things that are dangerous and the
more things you make off limits the more
tension you create and the funnier we
get
yeah i mean except for all the people
that got cancelled yeah
except for all the except for all the
famous comedians that are now working at
um
i've lost so many friends to death
recently and canceled culture
yeah those two um but i guess they both
cancel culture
it's funny because my wife is not a
common stand-up fan
she's disliked stand up it's a weird and
i don't think she ever
saw my stand-up she the first time she
saw me was at largo
i was doing a new bit and her manager
brought her
and i didn't little largo or the last
year
yeah and so um and then i found out
you know over the years that she just
doesn't like stand up she's more of an
improv person
stand-up is you know i love doing
stand-up
i i love what like but watching it
when when sebastian goes on when you go
on when burr goes on i'll like run in
and watch from the back
you don't run in and watch me i do
actually because you do a little bit no
i just told you i watched you
talk about anthony bourdain i heard you
were on stage i went up
no one said stand up for the past year
you fucking dick
all right take it easy i'm gonna take a
break whitney calm down and we'll be
back in a few minutes i didn't come to
your zoom show
you didn't nobody did wait but what was
i saying before you hurt my feelings
throw your head back again you have no
fillings
or are they all white uh i think i have
i replaced i had them replaced with
porcelain yeah yeah yeah
i had my replacement something a little
bit over tooth when i was like 12
like here and it was what gang were you
in
it was very traumatizing and i just
remembered it because we went to the
storage
and now you're all billy eilish yeah i
know look at me trying so hard you see
that documentary no i'm dying to see it
oh let me tell you what happens is it
good no
does she get famous in the end i've
watched so much uh i binge watched so
many
have you seen the hotel cecil
documentary at all you know what i
watched today because i'm
seeing everything else you're trying to
just i've been something you're talking
about i binge watched our ring doorbell
footage
today and it was so good
dude my ring door my ring footage is
fucking amazing
because i have comedians come over to
the podcast all the time i have a video
of donna rawlings
coming to the house ringing the bell
getting paranoid that he was gonna get
jumped and
running back to the gate have you seen
my ring
doorbell uh um my ring doorbell um
special special yeah no i do uh skits in
my ring doorbell
that's amazing i got actually the the
whatever motto for this podcast is
and that comes from ring uh surveillance
footage when i
took a couple nyquil when i got home uh
from the comedy store
and was chasing off coyotes yelling and
we caught on my ring cam footage
sent it to my agent to be like hey
doesn't ring cam want to like do
something with this and they're like
they're good no
you just you know we used to be our only
camera was a ring doorbell
thing in the front and we were gone for
about three months
and recently and we were in tennessee
just kind of potting because that's
where she's from yeah where nashville
god i love tennessee so anyway somebody
broke into our house when we were gone
they broke the back window and um
crawled through the window got cut
we didn't have an alarm on at the time
because it was always going off the cops
were coming
how did you know to look at that foot
were you just scrolling or got a
notification
or my gardener who broke the window once
before
because he hit a piece of gravel it was
the same window
but on a different side and he showed it
to me i thought oh they did it again and
now they're blaming it on a
thief but it really was i had my
assistant come over
and the security and they said yeah
somebody broke in
and it was just kind of a smashing
ground i have
yes i was thinking about this the other
day is like
as a woman that lives alone if someone
broke into my house
like a man i'd be like while you're here
can you just move this
shit like i just know what like i have a
bed that i need to disassemble you can
have whatever you want if you just help
me move this
down like i have when when i have so
many as a woman that lives alone i have
so many plans for when i get burgled
and i eat i like that i had one time i
was walking through
i was not my my proudest moment but one
time i was uh
uh i heard a noise downstairs and i was
i'm in a big house alone right
i hear a noise downstairs and once you
decide there's someone downstairs
there's no stopping everything you see
you have firearms right i fire pits
uh i do have dogs that will oh
um but so i was so when someone's
downstairs in your house
everything you see builds the case do
you know what i'm saying
isn't that amazing like when you like if
you look for something you'll find it so
i'm like someone's downstairs
and you're so adrenalized it's like your
heart's taking shit in your chest right
and i'm going downstairs and i see like
what is a pillar that's always been
there
since i bought the house and i'm like
that's he's that's him he's in a white
shirt and white pants like i was like
that like
everything turned into the burglar i was
like so such a creative mind
so scared and then um and then i walked
through what i was gonna do
and i was like okay anything valuable i
have literally the most valuable thing i
own is a necklace that i bought
at a auction for paws arc the elephant
sanctuary
that you and i both support i was trying
to drive the price up of a necklace
i remember that for the rich people to
buy it and then i
no one raised their hands so i spent
like six thousand dollars
on a necklace is that the most expensive
piece i've never worn it and i've never
no i've never spent that money on
jewelry for myself no six thousand i'm
not a jewelry person
i i am but i buy it vintage on etsy and
like
i like vintage stuff hey i got a laptop
you're not gonna do that i don't want
anything restorating except for the baby
clothes no this is in the garage
for my frozen eggs this is a beautiful
chandelier yeah
it would go so well in your house really
i'll send you please send me a picture
i have a bunch of chandeliers i need to
get rid of want to swap
no no damn it no i just don't need
anything chandelier for a chandelier
how about a chandelier for something
else
my thing is like if you come pick it up
you can have it yeah but so i
deci i had a plan and i was like okay
what i'm going to do is i'm going to go
get the necklaces because they're all
and i don't organ i need to organize my
they're all like out
and i was just going to grab them all go
to the top of the stairs and go
here's everything valuable i have like i
was gonna throw it down
i have a drive-through on the side of
the house i'll hand it out to you i was
just gonna say there's nothing up here
except these necklaces
and then my brain walked through that
and i was gonna throw it down and go
here all my necklaces good luck
untangling them
i was like picturing the burglar with
all these necklaces like trying to
untangle them
like fuck um so this guy breaks into my
house and he leaves blood
uh in places because himself
so the forensics teams came in and when
i say forensic
team i mean some actors from csi
[Laughter]
and you know they took some samples but
he didn't take that much he took a few
of my wife's designer purses
he went right to the bedroom he was in
and out pretty quick he didn't go to
much of the house
into the master but into the walking
dead got some of the purses
went into my side the smaller closet and
he got
some just a few of my watches that i had
like a rolex watch but it was my
father's that i gave my father
it was engraved in the back no and a
watch that lorne michaels gave me when i
left snl
you know after nine years he was like
your time's up
and the the most important thing he took
was an urn that had gary shandling's
ashes in it that i wore around my neck
so i said to the cop he said how do you
like do you call the pawn shops to try
to find out i don't say craigslist ebay
yeah and um and there's another one too
i forget the name of it it's like
something like um
off ashley wall or something ashley
madison
and uh but i could just call say do you
have gary shandling down there
do you have gary shelley's ashes and the
weird thing about those ashes was he
gave them to me before he died
isn't that crazy i remember i um
at your birthday party remember yes yes
yes you had a big birthday party
gary shanley gave me the most i mean i
obviously
am just a fan and he's a you know just a
legend
uh to me but he said something to me
once
that he just the way he said it how he
said it
i i i i would not no one else if anyone
else had said it i would not have
listened and i was up you know i'm
always working working work
like my thing is just gotta work your
fucking ass off all the time and
i was what you are the hardest working
comedian ever actor that's so kind but
you have to give yourself a break but
that's what it takes i mean this is what
are you on vacation ever where you just
sit on the beach
um i haven't i'm not a ski
no no no no what do you do what do you
do for a vacation um
i have gone on vacations before but my
vacations i always feel like when you go
with a guy you're just like fighting in
a hurry
with a girlfriend or uh i guess i could
my thing is instead of doing one big
vacation big vacations are stressful to
me because then you come back and you
have a million emails and then you have
to take a vacation from your vacation
and you're on the flight and that that
and you lose
i like to do little mini vacations
meditate yeah
when now this whole podcast is for one
long
meditation no i do my um i do i took a
attachment strategy class with this um
uh amazing guy george haas
uh attachment attachment strategy like
what's your attachment strategy or
attachment style like what would you say
your love attachment style is
preoccupied fearful avoidant right
um do you do morning pages no i
should you really should how many do you
do
my wife does them i try to for you for a
couple of days
kevin is so angry i've done nothing
today i i
you know i was just i just read the dr
john sarno book
because i've been having neck issues and
it's mind over body you know mind body
mind body yeah that kind of stuff and he
says it's all repressed rage
that's where our helmets come from yeah
so i thought well let me sit down and
and do write about my repressed rage and
i really have no rage so i have to make
stuff
up i was so angry at my ups man he knew
that package was out in the front
he knew i was home he did not you know
so i mean i
i did something called the grinberg
method um where
uh this woman were hell uh she's israeli
it's this
where she lays you on a bed you're just
in your underwear
she starts fingering you let me
visualize it yeah no she doesn't
i'm kidding and well first of all when
you meet her
i remember again the people at home
can't
see sometimes that are listening so you
have to act things out um so
you go you first of all when i met the
first time i met her her energy is so
calm it makes me realize how manic
everyone else is all the time and i tend
to feed off people's energy and i just
get
um i uh i go offline sometimes i don't
see that anymore you know
she is manic at all girls do you see him
as manic
but she's got this magical energy and
she
uh you go in and i remember the first
time you knew her hell
probably emily did you do you ever help
me with her or no was this a planter
feet in your plant like you had a plant
in the soil
or was this the ancestral trauma map
you've been through a lot of healers
with me
i feel like and we're here we're still
not healed
you are one of these people that's uh
you're into spiritualists no i just i i
was
i was just not i love crystals but not
because i think they're pretty i don't
think they're gonna heal your childhood
you know um unless you like use it to
kill your molester or something
unless you unless you bop your molester
over the head with the rose quartz
no but you scare the calories when you
say that
oh she said pop up like is she branding
again
should you try to make march again jesus
no so you go to this woman
and it was actually really helpful
because um
i was late like two minutes late and i
there was like it sounds like you're
late for everything i'm never late
i couldn't get a code in or something
and she opens the door and i was like
i'm so sorry i'm just i'm late and
she just was like why are you
apologizing
and she said it's super calm not at all
the way i just said it i probably could
never do the impression of it
and i just started bawling crying like
her presence was just so intense
and she just held a mirror up to how
ridiculous it is to apologize to someone
you're paying
when you're two minutes late and didn't
have the co why would i have
known and then we go in
lay down and she finds the place that
you hold your
basically muscle memory pain because our
muscles basically tighten
to protect us when we're in fear and
it's usually in our shoulders for women
right
and she'll like poke into your shoulder
and it you'll just
sob for two hours yes so this is a
faster way to do whatever you're doing i
think you sue her for that
i i'm calling ronan farrow as i talk
this through
um did you watch the woody allen i did
and
i did you listen to the book first his
book i listened to
woody allen's apropos of nothing
whatever it's called
i listened to his book and the first
thing that came to my mind was this guy
has had a stroke or something he sounded
really old mm-hmm
that's always what predators do they
start like trying to see more people
as soon as allegations come in they're
like i'm so feeble i mean i
and they started like yeah i even played
it for my doctor i said it sounds like
he's had a stroke
and my doctor says it sounds like he
said some neurological thing i'm telling
everybody woody had a stroke
woody had a stroke i'm spreading that
around yeah and then i find out that
i'm playing the audio book at two speed
slower and it should be
i have really hot takes on woody allen
that have nothing to do with all these
out like
i don't think annie hall is a
progressive female character this is my
hot take people think she's like super
pro
back then because she was in a blazer
it's because she's wearing a vest and a
blazer
she still dresses that way which totally
but i the character was like flighty and
insecure and lost and made a bit and
like
it was a character and by the way
confused but i'm just saying everyone
was like
he's such a feminist he made annie
like she was a very like weak
person that was dating was dating a
malignant narcissist
and she was wildly out of his league she
was an insecure
like airhead that was like minimizing
herself for this guy that didn't deserve
her
i don't like i never thought that was
like the movie the progressive movie
that everyone thought it was i was like
because she's wearing khakis and
unflattering clothes that doesn't make
this i'm just saying
i'd like to come for him for a couple
while we're on the topic i'd like to
attack
the work as well okay
i just feel like there's another
documentary about how
uh he molested my time
i just don't i just don't i don't i
don't like
when men uh hide behind being like weak
and like
impotent and like i'm a nerd and i'm
short and
like creeps can be short and insecure
too
but that is the root of a lot of
stand-up isn't it like self-deprecating
i'm you know i'm a nerd yeah but it's
too much you're rich you're a
millionaire you direct movies
he's not like that when he's directing
movies and saying go move duh duh like
you are confident
anyway i'm sorry for taking us off
course go ahead say what you were gonna
say
no i'm ruining your friendship with
woody allen right now if you go on stage
in front of a hundred 200 people to say
listen to me and no one else and if
you interrupt me a security guard's
going to leave you and remove you
and you have to pay to hear me talk
you're not insecure
that's right hot take
no one uses their hands better than you
let me tell you something
when i have a point if i don't if i have
a weak
argument my hands get stronger to make
it seem
a lot of information i start doing this
to make it seem like it's a better
argument than it is
you don't understand what i'm saying i
try to distract people
yeah um but uh what are you looking
forward to right now
the most um uh
us finishing like the five stories we
set up and never finished
no seriously should we i'm serious
should we go through and just pay off
all those stories we started sure
i never finished the story i always
change course that's what a podcast is
though
by what i'm looking forward to let me
tell you what one thing about podcasts
is by the way he does have to tell me
sometimes your hand
is in the other person's coverage
um no go ahead what you were saying i'm
looking forward to
figuring out what a podcast is i still
am unclear i was going to ask a podcast
is a vehicle to keep people's mind
on something when they're driving the
car or trying to get to sleep
and they probably don't always listen to
the whole thing yeah
and um i know i like to come back and
revisit a podcast if it was interesting
oh interesting
you know which one should you listen to
well
uh mostly howard stern but why isn't he
doing a podcast
because he has a radio show yeah and
and um but i i you know i have um
um stitches is that what's called stitch
stitch yeah radio yeah yeah yeah so i
keep all my podcasts there
oh stitcher stitcher yeah and i haven't
listened to a lot of them but like
the daily the daily is good that yeah
the new york times one yeah like that
um that guy's voice is very soothing
isn't it funny that we're going back to
radio
yeah yeah that's interesting the more
advanced i think it's more of a
multi-tasking thing
people don't want to do a lot of things
at once and listening
is um easier to do like i listen to a
lot of audio books
the best way for me to go to sleep is
when i was a kid i would hear my parents
and other people in the other room in
the living room talking and laughing and
i'd be in my bedroom and i
made me feel so comfortable i fell
asleep so now
i like to turn on a podcast and not even
pay attention just like
hear them talking and then i just drift
off oh wow
that's interesting that's so fascinating
isn't it i'm just saying when i
always just feel like i'm being boring
on a podcast but i think that's
the idea isn't to be too interesting to
where someone can't fall asleep for
example
yeah exactly if you stay awake to my
podcast i've failed
yeah that's true to a certain extent
yeah
the idea is to kind of drone on i got
this then in that case
i got it but i think a podcast is is
just a way to have a conversation
and hopefully have it be interesting and
also
um you know have it available for people
to listen to and try to create a
following and then get
sponsors and make money and then fill up
the theaters you know like we talked
about
like a lot of comics have podcasts and
all of a sudden they're selling out
these huge arenas
i just don't know if i'm supposed to be
um
you know how i mean we're coming you
know it's just like comedians i feel
like for the most part we're not that
funny when we're not doing comedy
especially when we're with each other
because it's like
i thought you say especially you
especially you i mean you just stopped
doing comedy ages ago you retired
uh no but i just mean comedians are kind
of
the one place where i feel like i don't
have to be funny or if i try to be funny
they'll think i'm corny
and a hack you know so when you're like
you're like funny with everyone in there
with comments you're like hey what's up
dude that's the one place
so it's weird that we're doing podcasts
now with each other because i feel like
we now have to be like we have to be
fucking funny around each other for once
but i will tell you nobody as a is a
good laugher as you
i really you really get stuff and you
laugh hearty
i'm one of the i feel like few comedians
that still like loves comedy and loves
comics
time to talk about student loans this
student loan
situation now that i am getting older
i'm in my 30s
my friends talking about student loans
in their 20s that's normal everyone's
supposed to have money problems and
they're
when i am with somebody who's 38 years
old and still has
crippling student loan debt a person
that works really it makes me
so angry you know you should be mad
we're talking about this school we want
you to be mad because ernest will help
you with this ernest is offering our
listeners 100
cash bonus refinance your student loan
debt at earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply now
ernest is giving our listeners a hundred
dollar cash bonus revive
finance your student loans at
earnest.com whitney
terms and conditions apply once again
you get a hundred dollar cash money
so when you visit to earnest.com
to your loan term not available in all
states
no no no no terms and conditions apply
visitor and cycle slash right now for
more details terms and conditions
earn a student loan refinancing made by
earnest operations
lnc and mls number sign 120
4917 california finance and law
license number 60 54
78 and 1 8 also
303 seconds she is sweet
401 north san francisco c8
for a full list of licenses i just had
this conversation
with somebody via text the other day
yesterday because i saw his special on
youtube
mm-hmm narrowing it down it's a six-part
special
danny jules or joles
i think it's joel oh yeah yeah okay
but he was really good and i never saw
him before and i was really kind of
getting tired of specials and i really
just i was just so sick of stand up yeah
and then i saw him i thought
that's refreshing you know it's really
he's really clever and smart
and funny and kind of a different
approach
so i thought you know that inspired me
to kind of
because you know when you're out at the
clubs every night you're seeing the same
comics
and then you see their specials i've
seen i saw that yeah
i used to live in the comedy clubs when
i first started as we all did
and i knew when the comic was going to
deliver his punchline i knew he would
swallow first with like a little
pseudo-indigestion and then do his punch
line
i knew every act you know i knew every
punch line every little
idiosyncrasy of the comic who do you
think should have had a bigger career
who should have mm-hmm like is there
anyone that should have had a bigger
career
we all should have had it yeah that's a
good point you know what you're like us
and it's not over for a lot of people i
used to tell gary shanley i said you
know gary when i
i used to go on the road and i would get
so excited because i think i'm building
having a show at madison square garden
you know and by doing these road gigs
but now you know i've been doing it for
so long when i'm on the road
it's not like i'm working i said i don't
think i'm going to be like selling out
staples center or anything like that he
goes you never know
you never know it can still happen but
the thing about the intensity of stand
up it can't
last that long you can't be selling out
madison square garden
over year after year steve martin you
know he burnt out after a while
every every major comic that has done
those venues
that have sold out and bragged about it
and yeah it's interesting you can't keep
that
momentum going i don't think you know
for for longer than
it's not sustainable or two or three you
know yeah it's just too hard
um you know i'm not i'm not saying that
my standup is like
great and i should be doing that stuff
but mine has always been just
very gradual you know comfortable kind
of a
because i think that's my personality
i'm not like a in your face comic i'm
more kind of dry and laid back
and that's kind of how my career is too
it's been really kind of
you know i've always been working i
could work you know
on the road forever if i wanted to yeah
you know i'm not to change the subject
but
before i forget this but i have three
things we have to finish okay on this
post-it note okay
and then i gotta go no i nope i was
interviewing neil
once the best and i was keeping him
longer than i should have
and after one question he goes okay
we're done here and he just got up and
he left
i thought that was hilarious oh my god
okay really quick okay you're gonna
um tell me oh the thing that gary
shandling told me i never said the
advice he gave me
it's so anticlimactic now but i was like
working working away because he had a
gym
with peter berg uh down on olympic
um he was very into boxing and i was
upstairs just working working working in
that gym right like between like
taking a training session and working
and he just looked at me and you know i
talked to him about a set that i had
seen him do at
a david lynch foundation charity show
where everyone
fucking bombs everyone bombs that chair
like these charity shows
everyone's bomb everyone's eating no one
wants to see comedy he came out and just
fucking
killed killed killed kilt was so funny
and um it was like amazing we were i was
i was at a table full of comics and we
were dying comics don't want other
comics to do well
we were dying and so i see him and i'm
just like hey just well you know like
i saw you that stuff was like amazing
and he was like
that was a nightmare the car was like he
had he remembered the night
every second of it and it was like i
like walked into some
[Music]
bad night where like the manager didn't
call the car and someone got like it was
just like not a good night for him but
an awesome night for me so i was like
bringing
up some trauma for him and i was like
okay i just like walked into a weird
horton's nest
and then we started talking about work
and he said something he's like you know
in comedy you can never make it too late
you can only make it too early see
that's what he said to me
he said those dreams could still come
alive
but it's like ronnie dangerfield 101. it
was just i just was like yeah why am i
rushing
like i'm only to get better and smarter
more worldly and more interesting as i
get older
i don't know what why would you want to
make it this young i don't have anything
to say yet
you know yeah so i just comedians it's a
our job is to have interesting opinions
like you have to go live your life
he gave me a lot of permission to be
like yeah i'm gonna go like live my life
and become interesting
it's like a blues you know musician
you've got to live a life yes have a
soul something to talk about and
for art to imitate life you have to have
life and he and
he changed my he changed the way i
approach
work in that moment and he obviously had
no idea and probably said it a lot and
it just like hit me at the right time
from the only person i would have
listened to it from
yeah that was a good good piece of
advice
so any day now i'm gonna start but you
gotta live a life
yeah withdraw from it yeah yes the most
uninteresting comics are the ones that
all they do is comedy and all they do
you know
yeah yeah but a lot of it is opinions
it's a lot of it is
you know point of views and observations
and also taking risks and and being able
to go into dangerous spaces which i
that's what i'm that's the only thing
i'm scared of anthony bourdain
what in l.a at the
comedy store in that moment that was
like the brave like
such a brave thing to do but it wasn't a
personal attack on him i didn't know him
of course
like i never would have had the balls to
say that some comics can get away with
things because of their persona
when others couldn't but you also i've
always been i don't want to say
gentle on other people like you're not
known for like a
mean attacking yeah all right and you
said it and kind of just like
just yeah it's just never it was
fantastic
did you do something on a parachute am i
making that up a parachute wasn't there
something about a parachute
i don't think so what was the anthony
warden bat i remember
it was um
that guy would just fucking kill himself
no no i just remember the audience going
like
and you're just fucking leaning in and
that is that is my favorite shit to see
from a comp
a comedian that's a true comment i thank
you and that's something you didn't go
oh
really you guys are you didn't even
fucking acknowledge it you just kept
going well i i will tell you you know i
haven't done that a long time that bit
because um it was kind of controversial
but but i've never felt so many
different levels
of reaction from a bit that i've done
before than that
i mean i i've seen people it's a risky
bit to do
especially at the time i see people
react in so many different ways
and then they get on board and they're
laughing and afterwards they'll come up
they say that bit
was hell it don't lose that bit that was
so good that's so good
and it really kind of made me um feel
alive
because like people kind of reacted to
it that way
you know and there's there was also a
part of me that made me
thank you for taking us through the
haunted house yeah that's what comedy is
you're supposed to take us into a
dangerous space
and laughing we're laughing we're
supposed to go into the danger zone and
we
stopped doing that with this careful
comedy this safe comedy you know what i
mean yeah
they're like we know you're joking we we
know
no i mean apparently you know like i
said i didn't know him but
apparently well loved and you know a
great show i never saw it
you know i always thought he never
really wanted to be where he was he
never seemed like he was that
impressed by any of the places he was
like all right
look at you jumping on the wagon i don't
want to feel like i'm plagiarizing you
but i always felt like he could like
take it or leave it i was always like he
seems pretty indifferent about
india yeah he seemed to have quite a
life
he had quite an adventurous life you
know all those different countries and
food and
you know seem to like as uh liqueurs and
yeah yeah but i just that's that is my
favorite type of comedy that i'm
afraid is is going to start to atrophy
or go away
because people are scared because people
are afraid of offending
yeah yeah no i mean i've had people walk
out on that bit
i've never had people walk out on me
before whoa it wasn't a lot it was one
table in san francisco
oh yeah you know yeah but i remember it
they were walking out because you were
a white man you were the patriot yeah
yes
but um but yeah i'm i'm open to more
bits like that
that really kind of um you've earned to
wake people up and
connect what's the point of you're not
feeling reinvigorated after you
like i i just feel like i was talking
about this this morning where
i went on this podcast and i was like
god i hope they liked me and i went on
first i hope that wasn't too far
like i found myself apologizing on this
podcast and i was like no it's my job to
come on here
it's not my job to be liked it's to be
interesting to go into a dangerous space
play devil's advocate and make sure this
conversation is interesting and then
probably to be polarizing yeah you know
but you want people going home and
talking about you
that's right when there's 10 comics on
the lineup
you want to be the one they're talking
about home yeah like quoting your stuff
and remembering your name yeah and
asking when you're going to be back
again
yeah but it's also where it's our job to
say things we don't always believe
just because we're exploring an area
that you've never thought about before
you know like we're going to go into
this dangerous place and then come back
you know yeah you're going to go scuba
diving at night and it's going to be
and then we're then you're going to be
safe again i mean i think that's one of
the things about bill burr's
appeal is that he takes you and down
this road
were you thinking this guy's not going
to say that oh he's going to be canceled
he's going to you know it's a roller
coaster
but anyway he gets away with it and
people love them yeah because because
there's if you the second you start
apologizing oh that's when it's over
yeah i feel like if you're just like i'm
fucking doing this this is what i do
this is what i've always done
this is the contract we signed with you
guys as comedians
we didn't sign a contract that you were
going to come in here and we were going
to say all the shit you heard at work
today
it's we're going to say all the shit
you're not allowed to say at work that's
the whole point of coming here
you know yeah and he doesn't fucking uh
flinch as soon as you flinch
they have the power and you're you've
got to be in control and watching
the pilot but watching you do that it
was just so i hope
i hope everyone gets to see it one day
because it was just sort of like
how long you've done like your you've
done this for um
over 40 years it was just watching you
dude it was like that is such a fucking
pro
like it was just no but a lot of times
like people have been doing it for a
long time and they're resting on their
laurels and they come in and they're
like
whatever well also i'm a people pleaser
not a people pleaser but
every comedian should be one i don't
like to make waves
but i do like to have something that's
memorable and
can i just you would make waves if kevin
neilman walked in and then just did a
bunch of safe comedy we're like all
right
that that's it like to me i'd go like yo
kevin nealon just blew my mind
yeah i'm i'm trying to decide whether or
not to do that anthony bourdain bit
right now or not
i do it in a special or out of whatever
but
somewhere or like when you're touring if
you don't want to put a special
are you you're doing these outdoor shows
right why wouldn't i put in a special
i'm just
i don't recommend it are you insane
what are you amazing you can't say that
on tv
no but i will say that he was beloved
and probably a great guy
totally but like the people that go i
know this butler you know he's kidding
he's kidding me
yeah but but could you do it uh film it
like all the bits that i'm like
i feel like i'm not gonna be able to get
away with that or whatever i've shot
some stuff like just sort of in my
backyard or
at these clubs and then i'll put it on
instagram and just be like let's see how
this goes
yeah you know yeah and kind of like
float it are you doing are you touring
i haven't started yet my schedule keeps
getting pushed back and also
i there was part of me that felt guilty
for trying to attract people that come
to
you know an indoor show here's what i'm
finding though if i felt like that too
but i'm noticing that the people that
come
either don't live with their parents
like people are going hey can't make it
this time i'll see you next time
like what i say to these cities is i'm
coming if you can't i will be back next
year
yeah so any shows that i've done in any
of these cities it's like phoenix and
salt lake all these ones i'm coming back
next year for the people that couldn't
come because they had a
weren't vaccinated and had immune thing
or lived with their grandparents or
whatever it was
yeah for me it doesn't i mean i don't
worry about my health because i'm fully
vaccinated
you know and i say that a lot you use
that a lot you know i say no no i'm
fully vaccinated what's the second shot
did you do two shots
the first one was fizer second moderna
and now i'm going with the johnson and
johnson
you want to mix it up yeah these are
loyal the cocktail one of them's got to
work
was the second one rough it was a little
rough yeah
because i took it in the butt
[Laughter]
uh no the second one you do know how to
really ramp up at the end
caitlyn jennifer's right with the killer
fucking come
in you know my keys in my hand right now
it's a tesla key so it's just a tiny toy
car
um um yeah my arm was stored for about a
week i couldn't lift it up
you know and then um i was a little um
fatigued
one day and i had a little bit of a
fever and some blood coming out of the
ear a little blood here
and a blood coming from the eye and just
a stigmatized coming out of my face
yeah and my skull split up
and i can't remember my wife's name good
thing i took all those photos
well you got to go on tour now we got to
keep these clubs in business
no i'm going to i'm i'm i'm you're
responsible i think i think my tour will
start back up in june
all right i would do this with you
forever and you know uh i love you and
respect you so i'm going to respect the
boundary and the fact that you're trying
to leave i'm not going to be
i'm not trying to leave i'm not going to
abuse my power
no i'm not going to pull a harvey
weinstein on you're not going to block
the door
you were yawning an hour ago that
doesn't mean i'm bored
that means i'm so relaxed you can't fall
asleep
[Laughter]
it is also this is a really late we shot
this at like eight and seven at night
this is the latest i've ever shot a
podcast i love you i have so many things
i want to talk to you when this is done
i know we have a lot to catch up on that
we're not allowed to say on camera
i love you guys don't ride elephants
kevin nealon.edu
thanks for doing this i hope this didn't
ruin our friendship no i think it
cemented it
[Music]
six
[Applause]
you